a torrent of mud sweeping through homes
destroying roads bridges and farmlands
these are Indonesia's worst floods in
more than a decade thousands of people
are cut off from the outside world
some still buried under heaps of mud
help is arriving but it's too slow and
it's not nearly enough for those who've
lost everything I didn't manage to
evacuate anything
I lost my small stall my house remains
but the windows and doors are gone
torrential rain began on New Year's Eve
triggering landslides and causing rivers
to break their banks mudslides and bad
weather are making it hard for rescue
workers to reach those stranded in
remote areas we have evacuated people
from several places it is impossible for
them because particularly layback is
badly devastated with no access for
vehicles nearly 400,000 people are
crammed into makeshift shelters in and
around the capital Jakarta in some areas
water has receded but the threat of
diseases like dengue and hepatitis A is
rising and our signs of more rain the
peak of the rainy season is in February
in March so we're still facing possible
floods we're now modifying weather so
the rain won't fall in the cities for
the people whose houses are flooded we
hope they'll stay in refugee compounds
so we can monitor their health and
reduce possible disease president Joko
Widodo has blamed delays and flood
control infrastructure for the
devastation and as these floods show the
effects are being felt by the city's
most vulnerable Priyanka Gupta
al-jazeera